[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
nous vivons et jour assez tendue et la
route est assez difficile
ils sont évidemment pour beaucoup
les troubles suscités
par des agitateurs
qu'il faut réduire et châtiés
certains française indigne
se sont lancés dans des entreprises
subversive et criminel
exploitants exaspérant l'irritation et
l'inquiétude d'une partie de la
population d'origine européenne
la nostalgie
de quelques éléments de l'armée
la rancune
et l'ambition de plusieurs chefs
militaires ou politicien disponibles
ces conspirateurs ont essayé et c'est et
sans doute essaieront encore
de créer des bouleversements à la faveur
desquels il imagine se saisir du pouvoir
la nation elle méprise et condamnent ces
gens
leur
complot et leurs attentes à
leur destin
ne relèvent
que des forces de l'ordre de la police
et de la justice le gouvernement est là
pour en répondre
et moi
j'ai pris quand il le fallait au besoin
je prendrais encore
les mesures exceptionnelles nécessaire
agassi twin red adair et c'est qu'on
prix du pétrole ont mené à bien la
première étape de leurs travaux pour
éteindre le puissant jet de gaz qui
brûle dans le désert ils ont débarrassé
le voisinage des amoncellements de
ferraille projetée par l'explosion sous
des jets d'eau continuelle sans lesquels
il n'aurait pu approcher la flamme à
moins de 100 m les hommes ont découpé
les barres d'acier tordus travail
harassant au milieu de l'air surchauffé
et de la vapeur travail dangereuses
morceau par morceau les bulldozer blindé
ont déjà dégagé du voisinage depuis 600
tonnes de ferrailles dont certaines
incandescente aurait pu ranimer la
flamme au moment de l'extinction quasi
d'où ils brûlent depuis deux mois n'a
t-on enfin parvenir à l'éteindre
c'est un événement historique qu'on a
célébré à la cathédrale de coutances en
suspendant un pendule au sommet de la
tour que vauban admirait et pourtant
elle tourne avait dit jadis galilée mais
pour démontrer pratiquement la rotation
de la terre il avait fallu atteindre
d'expérience qu'au siècle dernier en
1852 léon foucault avait présenté sous
le dôme du panthéon c'est l'expérience
du pendule de foucault qu'on vient de
réitérer à coutances et une très belle
assistance à regarder le stylet du
pendule entamé un peu plus à chaque
situation les deux talus de farine
disposaient face à face de deux choses
l'une expliquait déjà foucault ou bien
c'est le plan de simulation du pendule
qui tourne ou bien c'est la cathédrale
or le plan de simulation d'un pendule
demeure invariable donc c'est la
cathédrale qui tourne donc la terre ce
qu'il fallait démontrer
[Musique]
à londres devant l'immeuble du sunday
times les curieux étaient aussi nombreux
que les photographes pour assister à
l'arrivée en coup de vent du nouveau
conseiller technique du journal
londonien il est vrai que l'engagement
de l'ordre snowdon par ailleurs époux de
la princesse margaret a fait quelques
bruits en angleterre
[Musique]
place vendôme ceux qui aiment les élans
tourmentée du sculpteur atkine peuvent
aujourd'hui découvrir un zadkine
tapissier 11 tapisserie tissée à
aubusson tiré de gouache ou de dessins
illustrent cette nouvelle vocation d'un
talent depuis longtemps affirmé dans les
trois dimensions
zappin tapissier ce sera une nouvelle
arabesques de sa carrière artistique
et l'on pourra suivre de la statue à la
tapisserie la continuité d'une
inspiration très singulière
[Musique]
dans le même temps picasso lui nous
révèle dans une autre galerie ce qu'il
convient d'appeler l'époque vauvenargues
ce sont là les peintures récentes de 59
à 61 toutes datées de son château
provençal certains y trouveront le
rappel de motifs chers au picasso de
1925 et d'aucuns s'attriste seront
peut-être de trouver dans ses toiles des
concessions au figuratif en tout cas un
nouvel aspect de picasso
[Musique]
voici juste deux cent cinquante ans
naissait au château de candiac dans la
plaine languedocienne louis-joseph
marquis de montcalm qui devait être
l'une des grandes figures de l'histoire
du canada français ni les pierres ni le
paysage n'ont changé la fenêtre de la
chambre où il naquit s'ouvre sur un
horizon qu'il connut bien tout au plus
si les vignes ont remplacé les cultures
et les friches de l'époque ses larges
espaces ils les parcouru sous le soleil
avec les galopins de son village et du
petit bois où il joua enfants l'ombragé
toujours le même si les arbres ont été
remplacés
et au moment de son départ pour les
amériques il se retourna sans doute pour
regarder encore cette silhouette
rustique qu'il ne devait plus revoir et
ce fut la grande aventure à plus de
mille lieues de sa patrie il gardera
pendant trois ans le canada contre les
attaques britannique
paris le laisse à peu près sans renforts
et sans secours et il finit malgré des
victoires retentissantes par être acculé
dans québec où il s'enferme et qu'il va
défendre malgré l'infériorité de ses
forces
mais le 13 septembre 1759
obligé de livrer bataille il est blessé
à mort est contraint de capituler il
meurt le lendemain en même temps que son
antagoniste général wolfe commandant les
troupes anglaises
québec ad'ailleurs élever un monument
commun à ces deux nobles adversaire
québec parle toujours de montcalm et sur
la terrasse de la citadelle qui domine
le saint-laurent québec évoque encore la
ronde silencieuse de montcalm aux
dernières heures du siège mais notre
pèlerinage d'aujourd'hui ne sera que
celui de ce château rustique perdu dans
la plaine languedocienne est presque
inconnu où il naquit voici tout juste
deux cent cinquante ans
[Musique]
la normalisation qui a réuni en france
des ingénieurs du monde entier est une
notion moderne la chose existait déjà
pourtant dès l'époque des flèches de
silex et les égyptiens inventant
l'écriture normalisait sans le savoir
[Musique]
l'adoption du système métrique su en
france la première des grande
normalisation et et l'angleterre songe
dans ce domaine à se normaliser c'est
qu'on échappe pas aujourd'hui à la
normalisation le moindre four de
cuisinière qui n'a pas répondu aux
normes vérifié par le rôti électrique
n'est pas digne de ce nom
[Applaudissements]
mon siège doivent être capables de
supporter dix mille fois le choc de
notre poids
noma plat n'ont pas le droit de se
déformer
nos fers à repasser et tout notre
arsenal ménagers doivent répondre aux
exigences de normes de toutes sortes la
normalisation voilà le secret de notre
bonheur quotidien
si les pompiers de toulon et ceux de
marseille avait pu raccorder leurs
tuyaux les galeries de marseille
n'aurait peut-être pas brûler plus
simplement qui ne s'est sentie saisie de
désespoir devant un tuyau à gaz
parfaitement inadaptées à la prise de
tel problème n'existe plus avec la
normalisation dont les règles d'or sont
simplification et efficacité et dont le
domaine s'étend de l'avion le plus
moderne à l'harmonisation d'une bouche
de poêle avec le charbon en sac calibre
et
c'est encore la normalisation qui a
substitué aux multiples litres
d'autrefois des litres standard viser
que la ménagère peut faire reprendre par
tous mais attention la normalisation n'a
rien à voir avec certaines prolifération
bébé normalisé ne veut pas dire
stéréotypé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la campagne du plastique continue cette
offensive en disant monsieur andré
malraux a fait la plus pitoyable des
victimes une fillette de 5 ans qui a
failli perdre la vie la liste des
explosions s'allonge l'ouest comprendre
appelle la criminelle folie de ces
méthodes aveugle qui heurte toutes les
consciences
passant outre à l'interdiction de toute
manifestation
formulées et réitérée par le
gouvernement certains partis et
groupements voulu manifester à la
bastille contre l'action de l'oas des
forces policières nombreuses avaient été
massées pour faire respecter la décision
du gouvernement et de sérieuses
échauffourées se déroulèrent entre
services d'ordre des manifestants
laissant le triste bilan de 8 morts et
250 blessés
louisenthal est aujourd'hui le nom d'un
drame un drame qui avec ses quelques 300
morts rappelle tragiquement les
souvenirs de marcinelle et de courrières
dès l'annoncé de la catastrophe
la population entière de louison talent
ses portes et aux abords de la mine
chacun guettant la sortie des survivants
pour les interroger ou cherchant dans
les listes sans cesse renouvelée la
confirmation de son espoir ou de son
malheur et la gravité des blessures de
certains mineurs peut aggraver le triste
bilan
assez mort de la mine la mine a fait les
obsèques les plus émouvantes au 286
cercueils alignés sur dix rangs derrière
le carreau de la mine
la population sarroise les délégations
de mineurs venus de france de belgique
et du luxembourg et le président de la
république fédérale allemande monsieur
luc et sont venus rendre un hommage
solennel et déchirant c'est le deuil
d'un village le deuil d'une nation et
plus même le deuil d'un métier dur et
dangereux saluons ici les morts de
louisiane tard
[Musique]
m longueur à la température de zéro
degré de l'étalon rata nationale aplati
merisier déposé au pavillon de breteuil
à sèvres eh bien oui pour des
générations d'écoliers le pavillon de
breteuil demeurait le mystérieux repères
du maître étalon on ne sortait pas
souvent mais ce m a fait son temps il
offrait une précision de l'ordre du dix
millième de millimètre précision
dérisoire il nous la faut aujourd'hui au
millième de micron et c'est pourquoi
sans même le savoir la mercière a changé
de m depuis janvier dernier le journal
officiel est formel le maître de papa
est mort
messieurs terriens et à non au pavillon
de breteuil ont mis au point la nouvelle
définition désormais légal qui doit
remplacer notre maître à la hauteur des
précision exigée par les sciences
d'aujourd'hui du même coup sa mesure
exige à partir d'une lampe à krypton 86
un appareillage d'une complexité
saisissant
sachant simplement qu'il faut un
comparateur interférences y ait là
microscope photoélectrique robinet à un
interféromètre de mikkelson
titres électroniques
caisson étanche et calleur réfugiés où
le comparateur est un ferme et
[Musique]
sans oublier surtout une dalle de béton
de 30 pas de monter sur amortisseurs qui
assure une parfaite stabilité à
l'appareil
mais tout cet appareillage peut sembler
relativement simple eu égard à la
définition elle-même le m la longueur
égale un million six cent cinquante
mille cinq cent soixante trois mille
soixante treize longueurs d'onde dans la
vie de la can get sa correspondant à la
transition entre les murs aux deux pdc
fringues 2,5 de la tante d'une cape town
80 comme c'est simple et c'est justement
à cette heure de la grande-bretagne
mélancoliquement parle de se rallier au
système métrique car outre la tristesse
inhérentes à l'abandon de ces chaires
vieille chose qui était le yard l'on
sait le gallon il lui faudra payer la
transformation de toutes ces machines à
compter à calculer a enregistré à
additionner a comptabilisé des centaines
de milliers de machines
à perfide albion pourquoi n'avoir pas
accepté tout de suite voici un siècle et
demi ce pauvre m de papa qui n'était
alors tout bêtement que la dix
millionième partie du quart du méridien
terrestre ou à peu près
[Musique]
jeux mondiaux championnats du monde de
ski on ne sait pas exactement ce que
c'est depuis que les chancelleries s'en
sont mêlés quoi qu'il en soit pour une
semaine chamonix et la capitale
incontestée du ski alpin et c'est par
une mise en scène à grand spectacle que
débute cette semaine internationale des
sports de neige comme s'il s'agissait de
vrais championnats du monde
[Musique]
le rideau est levé
la jeune génération la classe biberon je
ne sens pas seulement les fans de johnny
hallyday ni les petits excités qui
sautille en choeur au son du tout risque
dans les salles enfumées la classe
biberon c'est aussi cela
le grand champion c'est une petite fille
elle a un peu plus de 16
[Musique]
sa joie à elle c'est de prendre des
risques de foncer sur une piste de ski
là au moins on bagarre on se bat avec
soi même c'est dur de s'entraîner pour
en arriver là et l'on se bat aussi
contre les autres championnes qui sont
là également pour gagner
[Musique]
la petite marielle goitschel fait tout
ce qu'elle peut pour gagner
[Musique]
elle a la technique la maîtrise c'est
déjà un grand monsieur
[Musique]
elle ne va pas gagner elle termine
quatrième du slalom géant à trois
dixièmes de seconde seulement de la
première
le temps d'une larme ou d'un battement
de cils
plus heureuse qu'elle l'autrichienne
eric ané terre secondes de l'épreuve et
la gagnante sa compatriote maria miam
[Musique]
messieurs les anglais tirez les premiers
on ne leur a pas dit deux fois au cours
du match angleterre irlande twickenham
match comptant pour le tournoi des six
nations trois minutes à peine est le
commencement de la rencontre les anglais
marquent en effet un essai entre les
poteaux
à peine interrompue par une mêlée
l'offensive repart et ce sont toujours
les anglais en maillot blanc qui tirent
les premiers
tiens tiens ça leur rappelle des
souvenirs assez marrant
et voici le grand maître à jouer et
chacha en pleine action ce n'est pas un
homme c'est une fuse
et là les anglais s'amusent comme des
petits fous
il est vrai que les irlandais ne ferme
pas le jeu ils ont attaqué de temps en
temps mais contre des adversaires aussi
a droit aussi rapide et aussi puissante
et anglais il n'y a rien à faire cette
nouvelle envolée du qatar et il les
estime
remarquez bien qu'on ne se fait pas de
cadeau pour s'emparer du ballon
voici le point final de cette rencontre
nouvel essai pour les anglais qui gagne
ce match par 16 à 0 de quoi donner des
frissons à l'équipe de france qui
rencontre bientôt l'angleterre
[Musique]
son voyage historique la première
traversée d'un transatlantique est
toujours historique le paquebot france à
voguer à 32 noeuds de moyenne sur une
mer agitée une mer agitée qui n'a pas
empêché les quelques 17 cents passagers
d'apprécier les plaisirs du bord
c'est ainsi que les invités du président
de la transat me suis rendu ce pari et
du commandant croisille ont partagé avec
juliette gréco et marcel achard le
gâteau monumental orné d'une réplique du
paquebot dont on apprécia sans doute
qu'il soit le plus long du monde
pour les générations qui n'ont pas
encore passé le cap des dix ans guignent
à l'offre est un spectacle permanent
[Musique]
quant aux autres que guignol ne
passionne plus ils ont trouvé en
juliette gréco imparfait professeur de
twist et le twist fit rage sur le france
ainsi passèrent cinq jours au bout
desquels se profile à la statue de la
liberté et lefranc pénétrait dans
l'essonne révoque survolé par les
hélicoptères saluée par les bateaux
pompes et de l'ujit semant des sirènes
d'un grand pope
au pied des gratte ciel de manhattan new
york lui a fait l'accueil grandiose
qu'il réserve à voici bientôt 30 ans aux
normes anti
[Musique]
à ces huit victimes paris a fait les
funérailles les plus éloquentes de la
bourse du travail où les cercueils
avaient été exposées avait reçu un
premier hommage jusqu'au cimetière du
père lachaise une foule immense dont le
nombre peut s'évaluer à plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes a
suivi le cortège
cortège silencieux seulement ponctué des
accents d'une marche funèbre et dont nul
cri du l'incident à troubler le
déroulement
des monceaux de fleurs gerbes coûteuses
ou abl bouquet ordonné le ton de la
piété populaire
ce cortège funèbre qu on les évalue à
150 milles ou à un million de présence
avait la valeur d'une affirmation
solennelle il ne faut plus que la paix
intérieure soit troublé
[Musique]
père lachaise la même foule le même
silence la tristesse des familles
éprouvées une fleur qu'on jette sur un
cercueil une femme évanouie qu'on
emporte et par dessus tout la conscience
d'un peuple
[Musique]
à baden baden le général de gaulle et le
chancelier adenauer ont consacré trois
heures dans leurs entretiens à l'avenir
politique de l'europe et nombre
d'observateurs ont voulu voir là la
preuve que le chef de l'état français
considéraient la solution du problème
algérien comme assez avancé pour se
consacrer plus largement désormais aux
problèmes mondiaux
[Musique]
non d'accord sur l'algérie et il en fait
réalisé monsieur louis joxe est venue
faire à l'elysée avec messieurs robert
buron et jean dreuil en présence du
premier ministre la relation des
entretiens tenus avec les délégués du
gpr a peut-être même at il apporté le
texte de l'accord est ce en prévision de
ses proches conclusion que le château
d'aulnoy où résident benbella et ses
compagnons a vu sa garde renforcée de là
ben bella qui a suivi le déroulement des
conversations sera libérée si l'accord
est conclu
[Musique]
alger cependant et toute les grandes
villes d'algérie vive la tente du grand
tournant dans un climat difficile la
vague d'attentats terroristes a
nécessité de la part du gouvernement
l'extension des précautions policière de
nouveaux dispositifs de sécurité de tous
ordres ont été mis en place le
quadrillage des villes s'est fait plus
étroit et certaines unités ont été
ramenés du bled où leur présence était
moins utile
durant chez noir ou s'allongent les
blocs d'immeubles construits en moins
d'un an qui abrite désormais les
services de la délégation générale
l'administration a sans doute commencé à
préparer l'organisation de cette
nouvelle algérie qui fera suite au
cessez le feu
dans les campagnes l'atmosphère se
manifestent bien moins tendu routes des
villages bourses et marchés laisse voir
une certaine détente qui n'existe pas
dans les vignes bien entendu l'action
d'un terroriste est toujours possible là
comme l'important n'est peut-être
peut-on voir dans cette atmosphère les
bouches d'une algérie où les âmes et les
communautés auront compris que tout
avenir ne peut être que dans la concorde
et la paix
[Musique]
la plus terrible tempête du siècle
peut-être s'est abattue sur le nord de
l'europe la marée haute poussé par un
vent soufflant à 160 kilomètres/heure a
livré à la côte allemand de l'assaut le
plus violent et dans la région de
hambourg où les digues ont cédé en même
temps que l'ale de déborder la
catastrophe a pris des proportions
effrayantes
[Applaudissements]
des groupes d'habitants sont restés
isolés parfois 30 heures les eaux ont
noyé des quartiers entiers du grand port
allemand
des moyens considérables ont été mis en
oeuvre outre des hélicoptères de l'armée
allemande et américaine
25000 sauveteurs de la croix rouge de
l'armée des corps de pompiers de la
police on aider aux évacuations et aux
recherches des survivants
plusieurs centaines de morts des
centaines de blessés quarante mille sans
abri un drame tel que la région de
hambourg n'a pas connu depuis 1825
[Musique]
la vie moderne et son agitation met à
rude épreuve notre système nerveux lors
même qu'elle exige de nous les réflexes
en parfait état de fonctionnement
un bon réflexe se traduit par une
réaction automatique rapide à une
excitation qui peut être visuel tactile
à ce titre il est le garant de notre
sécurité c'est ainsi que le contrôle des
réflexes revêt une importance
particulière chez ceux les conducteurs
des autobus parisiens par exemple que
leur métier oblige à évoluer dans la
jungle de la circulation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la faculté d'attention et la durée du
temps de réaction aux divers incidents
possibles font l'objet de tests très
précis
qui n'aura pas même des 8 millions de
conducteurs qui circulent en france or
si l'on sait que l'alcool perturbe l'ex
on se méfie moins de certains
médicaments de type très courant combien
d'automobilistes au moment
d'entreprendre une longue course après
une journée de travail ont en effet pris
l'habitude d'absorber radeau ping sans
doute ce médicament khiati léveillé et
supprime t-il la sensation de fatigue
mais s'ils n'assurent pas pour autant la
qualité des réactions au contraire ils
dispersent l'attention et réalise un
vrai prouilhe âge des réflexes
[Musique]
il en va de même du conducteur surmené
préoccupé surexcités qui se tournent
vers les fameux tranquillisants
[Musique]
c'est tranquillisant lui procure une
agréable sensation de bien-être mais ils
ralentissent aussi les réflexes et dell
qui normalement bloqué sa voiture mais
plus en mesure d'éviter l'accident
les doping et les tranquillisants sont
des médicaments il importe de ne pas
l'oublier c'est ce que feront pour le
bien général l'homme censé et le
conducteur prudent
ah
[Musique]
chamonix à l'heure du farniente avant
les grandes compétitions
l' arme secrète de l'équipe de france de
ski c'est la détente
du vieillard bozon périllat marielle
goitschel et tous les autres champions
s'efforce d'oublier dans les rires le
duel qu'ils vont livrer aux autrichiens
car les championnats du monde de ski
cette année se résume en une simple
explication entre française et autriche
on a l'impression que les autres skieurs
sont là pour mémoire sont plus faire de
la figuration intelligente en quelque
sorte
la petite explication entre français et
autrichiens commence bien pour la france
c'est charles bozon presque un pied gare
pour un skieur il a 29 ans qui donne le
ton dans le slalom spécial
à tournante de neige ne l'impressionnent
pas mieux même ils virevoltent entre les
portes du slalom comme un flocon
[Musique]
la légèreté la souplesse la puissance
bref la grande place
et pourtant il y a quelques années bosom
était infirme la colonne vertébrale
brisée par une chute il vivait enfermé
dans une coquille
aujourd'hui bozon et champion du monde
du slalom spécial l'épreuve qui demande
le plus de réflexes son sourire après
l'arrivée c'est celui de la revanche sur
le sort qui n'avait guère épargné
jusqu'à présent
cette gracieuse jeune fille porte le
même numéro que charles bozon le numéro
4 c'est bon signe
ce numéro 4 pour elle aussi se
transformera en numéro 1 après l'arrivée
du slalom spécial féminin il s'agit de
l'autrichienne maria mian qui ne se
laisse pas distraire suffit d'une
seconde d'inattention pour aller dans le
décor pour éclater comme disent les
skieurs
une seule consigne pour la petite
autrichienne droite au but
bravo mademoiselle vous êtes la
meilleure skieuse du monde mais
attention vous êtes suivi de près par le
bébé du ski français marielle goitschel
est battu dans le slalom mais elle n'a
pas dit son dernier mot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans la descente masculine française et
autrichiens joue à quitte ou double
lorsque bill viola franchi la ligne
d'arrivée à plus de 100 à l'heure plus
ses camarades de l'équipe de france sont
persuadés qu'il est champion du monde
tous ses autres concurrents cherchent à
leur manière le meilleur moyen de
franchir la ligne d'arrivée
le plus fort c'est qu'il y en a qui y
parviennent de toute façon ce n'est pas
lui qui sera champion du monde
[Applaudissements]
c'est là que les espoirs français
s'envole cette locomotive c'est
l'autrichien karl chance
quand on le regarde on en a le souffle
coupé
82 moyenne sur une piste parsemée de
bosses viola est battu de peu 49
centièmes de seconde seulement le
séparent de chambre qui a l'air plus
surpris d'être encore vivre
des récompenses pour bozon vainqueur du
slalom spécial et ses dauphins guy
périllat et l'autrichien henning
chance au coeur de la descente devant et
bill viola et l'autrichien si norman
pour marie-anne goitschel la petite
fille volontaire qui a coiffé marianne
yann sur le poteau au classement du
combiné féminin
france le meilleur skieur de l'année
le colonel john glenn a inscrit
aujourd'hui son nom dans la courte liste
des conquérants de l'infini et c'est la
première fois que le monde entier était
convié à assister à ce départ
extraordinaire d'un homme pour le cas ce
matin
dans le blockhaus de commandement le
compte à rebours après s'être interrompu
cinq fois arrive à sa fin 3 2 1
des parkings
dans toute l'amérique des pousuites ce
même départ sur les écrans de télévision
la fusée suit sa course on sait que le
projet comportait trois tours de la
terre on sait aussi que pendant les deux
derniers tours par suite de difficultés
survenues dans le système de contrôle
automatique grain dit assuré à la main
les opérations de stabilisation de sa
capsule quatre heures 56 minutes après
son départ la capsule retombé au point
prévu dans la mer des caraïbes et 18
minutes après son contact avec l'océan
était récupéré à bord du destroyer nord
elle sortait ayant accompli autour du
globe une randonnée de 130 mille
kilomètres il n'avait jamais cessé de
rester en communication avec la paix
transporté par hélicoptère à bord du
porte-avions randolph glen il était
l'objet d'une première réception dont la
chaleur laisse augurer l'accueil que lui
réservent une amérique qui oublie
aujourd'hui les déceptions de ses
précédents échecs glenn dans le cosmos
et passe bien des rancoeurs et peut-être
en fait à porte qui l'animent immense
abaissement
[Musique]
fallu 50 ans rugby français pour en
arriver là quelques minutes de jeu
seulement suffisent taux français
maillot français pour commencer
l'admirable leçon qu'il s'apprête à
donner aux anglais et pourtant la chance
n'est pas du côté de la france
cet essai il le manque de quelques
centimètres
sans doute est ce là reculer pour mieux
sauter la leçon continue rien ne serait
arrêtée là remarquable partie des avants
de l'équipe de france qui jouent comme
des trois quarts jamais on a vu cela sur
un terrain de rugby résultat les 1/4
d'heure de jeu premier essai pour la
france paie transforme albaladejo 5 à 0
on ose à peine y croire dans les
dribbles
et puis en deuxième mi temps ça repas et
là on va assister au plus bel essai qui
ait jamais marqué une équipe de rugby un
essai auquel on rêve parfois mais sans
histoire ce rêve devient pourtant une
réalité à toi à moi encore à toi à moi
et voilà comment tour n'a que trois
points
cet essai c'est en quelque sorte un
sommet du rugby à ce mec que nous allons
vous faire revivre l'un après l'autre
chaque joueur à toucher la balle
regardez
typique des tribunes de spectateurs fils
1 mais ce n'est pas terminé
cette spectatrice qui a du flair appui
avec beaucoup de générosité l'ultime
attaque française et c'est le troisième
essai transformé 13 à 0 pour l'équipe de
france qui est quasi certaine de
remporter le tournoi des six nations
dans paris comme en algérie la série des
plasticages continue aux champs elysées
même hier encore simple exemple entre
des dizaines d'autres le figaro était la
victime d'un de ces attentats si ces
manifestations marquent une volonté de
gêner la signature des accords elle
n'influe en rien sur la détermination du
général de gaulle qui a appelé à
l'elysée les principaux chefs des
circonscriptions militaires pour leur
préciser leur mission à la veille d'un
cessez-le-feu
par ailleurs et dans le même climat les
route qui mène au château tournoi
benbella et ses compagnons attendent
l'heure de la libération ont vu passer
de nouvelles forces de police le système
de sécurité vient d'être encore renforcé
et des auto mitrailleuses anti-aériennes
ont même pris place dans les environs du
château
quant aux grandes villes d'algérie alger
ou oran chaque journée il compte deux
nouvelles victimes coup sur coup une
série d'attentats a ensanglanté le coeur
même d'alger de la place du gouvernement
à bab el web
la police et l'armée ont dû pour
empêcher une extension possible du drame
bouclé le quartier
sursaut dramatique qui annonce peut être
une fin il est possible a dit le général
de gaulle que dans les jours qui
viennent une douloureuse épreuve
s'achève
le retour de glen à cap canaveral de
trois jours plus tôt il était parti pour
le cosmos l'amérique a voulu qu'il soit
triomphal
de l'aérodrome de st patrick à la base
des fusées ce fut pour glen sa femme et
ses enfants une suite ininterrompue
d'acclamations ainsi un peuple le
remercier d'avoir réussi en son nom un
exploit dont on n'oubliera pas de sitôt
les péripéties
il était 9h 50 aux usa à 160 km de la
terre la capsule mercury se séparaient
comme prévu du dernier étage de la fusée
glenn qu'une caméra automatique à filmer
commençait son premier tour de tête de
petites fusées latéral entraient en
action elle provoquer un retournement
qui plaçait la capsule en position de
croisière une opération délicate encore
la stabilisation dans l'angle de vol
obtenu par le moyen de fusées laterrade
qu'elle prenait son premier repas au
dessus de l'afrique plus ré de boeuf et
de légumes bouillis extrait d'un tube de
matières plastiques
trois fois le cosmonaute faisait ainsi
le tour de la terre il fallait
maintenant entré dans l'atmosphère
terrestre
de nouveau une manoeuvre difficile
l'allumage des rétrofusées qui en
ralentissant la course de l'engin allait
permettre d'amorcer sa chute
à 14h40 le parachute été déployés les
amortisseurs libéré et 4 heures 56
minutes après son départ glenn touche à
l'océan
l'extraordinaire aventure était terminée
[Musique]
elle va ta john glenn d'être accueillis
maintenant à cap canaveral par le
président kennedy et devant les
techniciens qui avaient préparé le
voyage celui ci lui remettait la
médaille des services exceptionnels
clem a réussi et la réussite de glen à
effacer les échecs antérieurs
l'homme que l'amérique fait aujourd'hui
avec tant d'enthousiasmé
c'est avant tout celui qui lui a redonné
la confiance et l'espoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lors des collections d'été a sonné pour
tout le monde bon les messieurs dans les
salons du crayon ou le groupe des cinq
toujours à l'avant garde de la mode
masculine a lancé son offensive de potes
le triomphe du gilet ne coupe pas
l'appétit et l'audace des détails
semblent même d'un défunt en dépit de
l'affinement de la silhouette beaucoup
d'indépendance et beaucoup d'imagination
assez pauvre un mot bien perdu leur
effacement vestimentaire d'autres fonds
[Musique]
réapparition de la ganse veste ferment
aux pantalons étroits sans revers taille
plus marqué telles sont les
caractéristiques de la saison est le
signe général d'une couleur le blanc
four avec c est qu en doublure ainsi dit
l'axiome les lions de la mode plaistow
fan d'art dit aussi l'axiome les femmes
aiment les animaux
coup d'état chez dior ou presque alors
qu'on attendait le succès de toutes les
ampleurs d'une taille fine à sa place ou
même remonter voici que mark bohr dans
une collection qui n'a dit on jamais eu
tant de fidèles à ramener la jupe aux
genoux et la taille aux anges
la guerre de la taille est donc déclarée
[Musique]
longueur de la jupe droite la plupart du
temps légèrement diminué ceintures sur
les hanches qui allonge le bus la ligne
dior en contradiction avec toutes les
prévisions créer une féminité nouvelle
il est trois grâces de cette année sont
authentiquement des grâces nouvelle mode
d'ailleurs avait est désinvolte courte
akol dégager sa compagne de juba
facettes ou de quelques plis c'est la
blouse fait sa rentrée
tous les robes robes d'après-midi robes
de cocktail silhouette droite même dans
l'emploi mais des pertes des ruches et
des volants sonne l'heure des chics des
saisons plus dépouillé nous avait fait
oublier
[Applaudissements]
de longs fourreaux créer l'ambiance du
soir c'est un soir de paris une
silhouette de paris une saison de paris
avec ses arpèges et ses points d'ordre
pianissimo
fortissimo diorissimo
[Musique]